kyle hendricks 31 years old native of
mission viejo california rangers drafted
him
in 2011. you know the story
the 1-1 tap softly third base side kyle
pounces on it and throws him out first
one of machado was chopped out to
alcantara collects and throws to first
two quick outs here's the o2
here's a swing and a pop-up
and this is going to end the inning by
as it short we'll slap the leather on it
one two three for hendricks made it look
easy on the bound is ryan weathers for
the padres takes the mound 12th
appearance seventh start for the
left-hander his first appearance of his
career against these cubs
strike three knew it takes with him the
first strikeout for ryan weathers of the
night frozen with the fastball contreras
looking for something else frozen pizza
right down the middle the return to the
lineup of anthony rizzo anthony coming
back from having some back stiffness
shift out against rizzo
and he drills one out of the left center
field
pro far over to collect it rizzo with a
laser single welcome back chris
2-2 to buy his left wade and rizzo is
picked off by a lot he is very out over
at first base
wow
we're done with one without a score from
chicago and ryan weathers will go to
work against javier baez 3-1 now
outside and that's ball four here's
wisdom patrick had the big biggest day
of his brief big league career yesterday
with two long home runs
that's drilled left field that one way
back there
look out wavelength
and that is crushed
wisdom another homer
two yesterday
and one here tonight he hits it into the
back portion of the bleachers and it is
two nothing
he's gonna pass hobby here in short
order as he races around the bases and
he's gotta be loving life right now
patrick wisdom we talked about you know
the long journey for a
high draft pick but he is feeling it 94
mile an hour fastball moving in a little
bit
he's able to barrel it up watch it fly
and
off he goes this is a fun story here
patrick wisdom
kyle hendricks has gotten the first six
in a row how about this yes
14 pitches through the first two innings
fewest he's ever had at 185 starts
the 1-1
on the ground to first speaking of gold
gloves rizzo
went up one down
in the year left field
and jock
[Applause]
[Music]
on the ground and through into right
field a base hit for weathers his second
of the year
and a two out base hit first base runner
to reach for the padres and there goes
the no-hitter
that one is in there and hendricks with
his first strikeout
and kyle up 31 pitches
bottom of the third as the cubs lead it
two nothing 3-2 pitch bounced up the
middle there's a base hit to center
contreras will aggressively round first
he's going for second base the throw not
in time how about that
jerickson profar
just lobbed it into the cut-off man
tatis there wasn't even a play on him at
second base as he slides in
now that is a well-deserved two-base hit
for contreras
now bryant sends one to center field got
under it and profar shy of the track
will make the catch tagging at second
heading to third is contreras and he
will be out at third base
as sony had to get out of his way to
make the call but he does well the jerks
and profiles got a very very good arm
and uh
he's out
two zip cubs lead it on a gorgeous night
and a breaking ball got him to chase
struck him out second strike out of the
night for kyle and there's two down he
is locked in it's as if he heard us say
he's only got the one strikeout so far
he said okay you want one of those here
you go two down in the fifth and it
brings up victor caratini the former cub
3-2 is driven out towards deep right
center field that goes happen it is gone
victor caratini returns to chicago hits
a home run a solo shot to get the padres
on the board in the fifth victor
carratini got a nice applause
from the cub faithful yesterday
and i'm sure there are some cub fans
applauding victor
as he turns on that kyle hendricks
change up
hail to the victor
sharply hit through the left side and
weathers is two for two
he's got two of the four padres hits in
this game
here's a drive out towards deep left
center field back goes peterson looking
up that ball is gone tommy fam hits a
two-run home run and just like that the
padres take a 3-2 lead
that was fast
trailed two to nothing carrotini it's a
solo shot ryan weathers with a hit and
tommy pham connects on his fourth home
run of the year
3-2 padres just like that sergio
alcantara at the plate
this is london for a base hit in a
center field
keep it going now it's san diego up
three to two here in the last half of
the fifth kyle hendricks at the plate
evil the two strikes gets it down throw
the second ball he's out there
and safe there
got the lead runner nicely done how was
that plate just made to get the lead
runner
man machado charging
he's going towards the first base he has
to throw that ball behind him his
momentum going the other way and then
fernando to pick that ball 0-2 now
[Applause]
a titanic two-run homer
wilson contreras has given the cubs the
lead his ninth of the year
and doing it with the long ball again
high up into the bleachers and it's 4-3
for contreras is liking and he shoots a
look back at carotene you're really
going to try that on me
old buddy
4-3 the cubs have the lead but that is
not the story right now as we move along
to the bottom of the sixth inning hassan
kim has taken over at shortstop for
fernando tatis jr not sure why but never
a good time when he comes out of a game
in the middle of a game craig stamen
scored upon in all three of his outings
during this current road trip
and a swing of the miss struck him out
went to the curve ball to get it stamen
records his first strikeout it's a big
one of peterson two down
fly ball center field mateo
makes the catch and the cubs strand a
pair very reliable ryan topera comes on
for the 26th time
24 and two-thirds innings he has pitched
to a 2-5-5 e-r-a
a swing and a miss there and a strikeout
as tepera
gets carrottini one away
[Music]
line to left peterson moving over jack
makes the ground
machado lines out to paris does good
work the kraken has been released out of
the cubs bullpen
23rd appearance 0-8-2 e-r-a
outside the corner later struck him out
paints the outside corner with 99 and a
1-2
struck him out two down caratini weights
two outs three two
fastball right there got him
ball game cubs win
craig kimbrell lights out